I hate insurers is it wrong to pick up
girls in a dungeon season two we episode
one we kick things off balloon Bell Lily
wealth and Mikoto
on a dungeon run where they are now able
to hold their own in the middle floors
after they returned we learned that
wealth had gone up to level two and
Belle is already closing in on level
three well at a pub afterwards unwinding
they are approached by one who is
insulting Belle and the others Belle is
trying his best to not let it get to him
until he insults Hestia so fel loses his
temper and gets into a fight with one
and the Apollo family things start out
pretty well for Bella and the others
until IKEA anthos a level 30 in the
Apollo family steps in and manhandles
bell beating him to a pulp
the next day Belle is approached by
Daphne and Cassandra who are part of the
Apollo family and want to invite him to
a banquet that Apollo is having while at
the banquet Belle and Hestia are
approached by the spiteful apollo who
was upset about the fight in the pub he
challenges Hestia to a war game and if
he wins Belle will become a part of the
Apollo family he episode two Hestia
refuses the war game challenge so the
next day apollo sent men to attack
Hestia and Belle at their house look at
those catches up to them and again
easily messes a bell in their fight
luckily an archer named Nizar riskiest
as well as the talk and mikazuki family
step in to aid in their escape really
and wealth make it to them and act as a
distraction but then Lili runs into
xanies who she apparently has some
history with she then suddenly tells
well that she's going back to the soma
family to not cause any more trouble for
Belle realizing they can't escape
Hestia and Belle go to Apollo and accept
the wargame challenge Belle realizes he
has to get stronger if they want to win
so he meets with ice to request that
they train together again which she
agrees to he episode 3 we get a look at
xanies talking with Lily about her rare
transformation magic that was supposed
to be a secret and says that she's gonna
have to serve under him for the rest of
her life
well Belle is off training with ice
Hestia and wealth worked with the Taku
mikazuki family to plan an attack to get
Lily back meanwhile a meeting is held to
decide the rules to the
game Hermes is asked to draw randomly to
decide the rules and gets each which is
the game where numbers matter the most
putting Hestia at a massive disadvantage
to make things more fair apollo agrees
that they can have one helper that isn't
from a family of audio first things
first though they have to get Willie
back so they attacked the soma family
where she is being held captive while
they're fighting in the courtyard she
gets two soma to beg that he stopped the
fighting he makes her drink the divine
wine which makes anybody that tastes it
completely addicted to it even under the
strong influence of the wine she still
manages to see what's important to her
and requests that he stopped the fight
some was amazed that she's coherent and
still determined after having some of
the wine so he puts a stop to the fight
as well as allowing her to leave the
family in the last couple of scenes we
see that wealth and Makoto asked their
respective gods to let them join the
Hestia family for the war game as well
hermes is also able to recruit Ryo as
the helper as she is the only fighter
not a part of an old audio family yep so
for now we jump ahead to the start of
the war game and siege the apollo family
must defend a commander he a Cantho
story days or defeat the attackers
commander which in this case is bell to
win Ryo launches her attack first using
Wealth's magic swords while her and
makoto are taking care of the bulk of
the army bel uses his Argonaut power to
blast his way to yak at those and
ultimately defeats him after he lets his
guard down
Hestia was promised whatever she wanted
if she won so she demands all Apollo's
property be confiscated his family be
split up and finally he is banished from
audio since their old house was blown up
in the attack by Apollo the Hestia
family moves into Apollo's mansion while
also getting their new emblem be Episode
five after the war game Belle had gotten
enough experience to promote to level 3
as well as being labeled commander in
the Hestia family the next day they hold
a recruiting for the Hestia family and
since the war game their popularity has
skyrocketed so a ton of people showed up
to join Mikoto exposes Hestia in front
of all of the applicants revealing that
Hestia is 200 million volleys in debt
obviously nobody wants to be in that
kind of debt so all of the applicants
bail the debt is actually to Hephaestus
in return for her making Belle's knife
episode six
everybody was noticing something was off
with Mikoto so Belle welp and Lilly
follow her one night she goes to meet
with chika and the two of them go to a
red light district bill ends up getting
lost in the crowd while wealth and Louie
go on to confront the two about what's
going on they explained that they're
looking for a friend from their homeland
that was supposedly working in the red
light district as a prostitute over to
Belle who's having a terrible terrible
time as he gets kidnapped by I see and
some hot hookers who are basically gonna
rape him that poor poor protagonist how
will he ever escape this dire situation
the raping can't happen in a plaza
though so he's taken to East hearts
house which is a brothel and then meets
the hottest of all the hookers named
brine of course fried wants to rape him
also and all of the hookers start
arguing over who gets to rape him first
and in all this commotion he decides you
know what I should leave nothing good
comes from me staying here after
escaping he runs into Hajime who is a
Renard which is basically another word
for Fox Girls the Fox felt good to get
to talking and we learned that how to be
Mei was disowned by her family she
angered her father and was sold to the
East our family to work as a prostitute
Wow that's happening we see that Hermes
had brought a mysterious package to e
star who seems to be planning something
with
episodes of n Phoenix de Bell learns
that how to he may was actually the
friend that Makoto and chica saw were
looking for Mikoto tells Belle about
their childhood and how hada he may was
of noble birth so she was always kept
alone Mikoto felt bad for her so her and
her friends would sneak her out at night
to go on play just so she could have
some sort of social life she actually
came to audio from the far east to make
money and sent back to her shrine that's
when she ended up hearing that she was
deceived by a heartless person and sold
into slavery bill and Mikoto get more
information from Hermes and learned that
they can buy her if they have the money
however after learning that how did he
may as a renard Hermes tells them that
he brought each star a killing stone
that night but doesn't explain anything
about what it is over to each star who
has some feud going on with Freya and
learned that Freya is interested in
Belle after hearing about this each star
orders her followers to go and capture
Belle she also mentions that the full
moon and killing stone ritual are coming
after the ritual has been fulfilled she
plans to declare war on Freya using
Belle to provoke her and in the last
scene aya isolates Belle from the others
and attacks him in the dungeon he
episode 8 cloud of he may gives Isis
some buffs before the fight and she
quickly defeats Belen Mikoto before
kidnapping them hot Okemah gives Mikoto
the keys to her cell allowing her to
escape and also breaks belfry fling with
him through some tunnels over to talking
mikazuki who tells Hestia more about the
killing stone it's a forbidden magic
item that seals away the soul of a
renard allowing the use of the powerful
renard magic known as you Jitsu the
ritual to move the renard soul to the
killing stone has to be done on a full
moon which just so happened to be that
night I shook Hatch's up to Belle and
takes back how to he may for the ritual
and Belle is chased off by the other
Ishtar followers II episode 9 Bella
Mikoto know that they can't just let her
die so they go back to break hodduk he
may free he uses his Argonauts skill to
fight his way to each star who explains
how to heem his jiu-jitsu is level
boosting which would allow her entire
family to level up giving her the
advantage against Freya
Belle has a skill that allows
and to resist each stars charms so he
uses that to escape and get to the
ritual site where Makoto is Makoto gets
into a pinch so she has to use some sort
of self-destruct to stop the ritual and
knock away the other guards while also
dealing severe damage to herself
this gives Belle the chance to save how
to he may while also destroying the
killing stone preventing the ritual
altogether
each episode and Freya apparently knew
about the plants each star was making so
she attacks the red-light district with
her horses I'd rate all of these
brothels being burned down to be right
up there with that one church that
burned down in France but what are you
gonna do Belle gets buffed by hot Akeem
is power to fight against the toad
rapist well that's going on Oh Todd had
to come across Makoto who was still
badly injured and heals her with a
potion back on over to Belle who knocks
away Bryan and she is later found and
taken care of by Oh Todd with her out of
the way only Aishah is left standing
between him and hada he may even though
I she is implied to be the bad guy we
get these glimpses showing that maybe
she's not all bad and really just wants
what's best for bail and hatta he may
next we get a short scene with Hermes
who is apparently orchestrating most of
these events because he wants to turn
Belle into a hero about audio but that
aside Belle uses his Argonaut fireball
to knock I shut out of the fight and
finally secures how to he may safety
Freya
uses her charm ability to walk through
any remaining guards and gets to each
star J then proceeds to bitch-slap her
off a ledge and there is a massive light
showing that each star was summoned back
to heaven never to return to the lower
world again episode 11 I she gives her
farewell tejada he may and the others
saying that she might join the kingdom
of rocky is army clear the Ares family
with a massive number of soldiers who
are actually in the process of attacking
go to audio there's just a tiny problem
in the fact that they're really weak so
the Loki family are holding off their
entire army by themselves we also
learned that how to he may never
actually slept with anyone while she was
a prostitute because she'd get nervous
and pass out whenever she saw in those
body which is all well and good for the
anime but we all know that wouldn't
any guy if anything you could argue that
it makes a lot of things much easier
some people would probably pay extra for
the trick that passes out naturally
howdy he may becomes one of Hestia's
children joining the family later on
hermes meets with belle after things
settle down and talks about the three
great quests it's a story about how the
world is waiting for a hero and what the
world really wants remote audio it also
involves the defeat of three great
monsters that escaped from the dungeon
two of the monsters behemoth and
Leviathan were already defeated by the
Zeus and here our families when they
were the strongest and not audio the two
families were wiped out soon after
leaving just the black dragon that
resides in the dungeon hermes is hoping
that Belle will become the hero to
defeat it and complete the three great
quests back over to Ares who is sick of
losing the war against the Loki family
so he goes to kidnap a goddess and hold
them ransom of course who'd have thought
Hestia is the goddess at he ends up
kidnapping while she's out doing a favor
for somebody else Belle learns about
this from ice and the two of them go to
get her back with the help of a speak in
the last scene a fight breaks out and
during all the commotion Belle and
Hestia fall off a bridge into a river
with ice following soon after II episode
Wow I saved them from the river and
brought them to a nearby village we then
meet Karm who is a sickly old man that
gives them a place to stay and rest the
next day while out at the village Belle
comes across massive black scales that
came from the black dragon people built
shrines around the scales and give
thanks to them because they protect the
village from monster attacks ice on the
other hand is extremely bothered by the
scales insinuating that she has some
history with the black dragon later on
Carm talks with Belle about his goddess
who was killed because he couldn't
protect her jump past some festival
fillers and the old man is on his last
legs from his illness
Hestia meets with him and he asks if
when he gets to heaven will he see his
goddess again this gets Belle thinking
about him in Hestia apparently when he
dies Hestia will remember him but he'll
return to the lower world without memory
of her and he doesn't want to fall in
love
her only to leave her and break her
heart she takes some time to reassure
him that she'll always come and find him
no matter what so they can be together
forever
I'm gonna be doing the future season you
can find that in the left side whenever
I'm finished with it or you can check
out all of the is it wrong to pick up
girls and attention recaps on the right
side you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing I
hate more than intros is outros